Hãy tưởng tương, các mù trí hoân màn ét với ra lạnh đống 2 thử phẩm biên dối với Thailand.
Sau khi phía bong cấp đơn phương thực hiện đậm thải thương tự.
Lạnh được đưa ra chung bố cảnh, các thằng ra tăng giá nước.
Sau phụ đồng độ bú trang, các vừa gần đến Pria, Bia, Hồi của Itheng năm.
Theo 1 màn ét, miếp Thai Lan đống các trạm kiểm soát biên dưới mà không thông báo trước,
đã gây an hưởng tiêu cực đến thương dân hay bên.
Phà nước ngược lại, các mù trí hoặc đống cực khẩu cho khu khí và chua ăn.
Đồng thời tuyên bố sẽ dưới bên lạnh, nếu Thailand không thay đổi lập trường.
Bây giờ, phía Thailand của 2 chụi biết, vì đồng thời khẩu trong sai thạc của ước tình bú ruy ra.
Nhằm bầu đảm ăn thật tông cậu và ăn lạnh thổ.
Được rồi, đặc nhiệm suy ra nơi rơi được chào quên kiểm soát tòn bộng vào đặc biên dưới tại khu vực này.
Các thằng chứ đó, đã bị đầy caong sau bộ dòng gì kiếm của định đầm dưới lạnh đạo hành hứa.
Kính quan hệ giới chính phủ Thailand và con đối nước này trên đến phức tạm.